[Music]
welcome to DEA 104 the road to
intelligent transportation my name is
Chris and along with my peers down here
is F and Andrew we're going to be
talking to you today about how Google
and the Colorado Department of
Transportation cidade are leveraging
Google cloud platform to bring
intelligence efficiency and
interoperability to see dots
transportation network a quick show of
hands who commuted into San Francisco
this morning all right
half or so who enjoyed it and if this is
a you know interactive session I'd ask
you in the back did you go by bus or by
shuttle so you could actually have some
relaxing time and I would expect most of
us didn't so while we're not solving
that problem today that is one of the
goals that we have in this partnership
is to try to alleviate traffic
congestion to help all of us improve our
commutes before we dive in a quick
reminder if we can accept questions to
the Dory app which you can link to from
the next application and enter your
questions and at the end we will have
time for both live Q&A from the mics as
well as answering questions from the
dory so let's dive in so safety has
always been a number one goal for
departments of transportation while
fatality rates have decreased over the
years in recent years we've seen an
uptick in the number of fatalities so
what's causing this change well the
number of vehicles on the road are
increasing faster than the number of
people from 2016 to 2017 we saw an
increase of 1.6% in the number of
registered vehicles compared to a point
8 percent increase in the overall
population this is leading to more
congested and dangerous roadways and DLT
budgets aren't increasing if anything
they're shrinking while construction
costs are rising - to answer this
transportation problem we shouldn't
continue to do the exact same thing
we've always done which is building
more roads wow that's definitely needed
it's something we'll definitely do
there's not enough space to continue to
do that and also it's extremely costly
and it takes years to see an impact to
congestion for new construction one way
we could improve upon an optimized
traffic management is by viewing the
roadway as a highway for information
versus a highway that carries vehicles
DLTS have spent decades deploying
traffic management solutions that
produce massive volumes of data side
fire radars toll meters weather stations
traffic cameras harnessing this data
from the roadway will help us optimize
traffic both now and into the future the
good news is that the data we need does
exist the not-so-great news is that it
generally resides in very different
places and is generally disconnected
leaving us with a fragmented view of
best of what's happening on the roadways
and there's many different
transportation data sources that exist
but again they live in different places
critic critically critical data that we
could take advantage of now such as
interacts GIS data Amber Alerts traffic
cameras are all over the place and even
key data sources like Waze and Google
Maps without a clear understanding of
what's happening on the roadways our
communities pay for mobility and
sometimes with their lives
but what if we could bring all this data
together and even let data be the driver
for traffic management we can enhance
situational awareness leveraging current
and historical data both situational
data of weather data traffic data to
respond to traffic incidents in near
real-time the moment they happen we
could coordinate response across
courtesy patrols towing maintenance law
enforcement emergency response to
respond to an incident based on where it
is from community feedback we could
assess roadway needs using data points
like traffic volume and frequency
weather events community feedback to
understand where we need to do repairs
in a predictive way on the roads with
all this data brought together in a view
that you know best and interface such as
Google Maps you can harness the data to
answer some key questions things like
how is traffic changed over time what
alternate routes can be utilized when
this congestion expected to peak and
where are the most traffic roadways we
can visualize this data with Google Data
studio or partner solutions from looker
and tableau you can overlay your
insights on a real-time view using
Google Maps once the data is centrally
organized and available for both
historic and real-time analysis we can
make data-driven decisions helping to
make roads and drivers safer so why did
see that choose Google Cloud 2 to build
its data analytics system Google
supports data at petabyte scale securely
with our best-in-class data analytics
and machine learning capabilities to
inform real-time decisions and to
operate roadways for almost two decades
Google has been advancing the state of
the art for data analytics
starting with our initial research paper
in the Google file system in 2002 going
to our MapReduce research in 2004 and
our no sequel database BigTable research
in 2005 we've been advancing the state
of the art and creating a revolution
that the open-source community has taken
and around that have built what many
would say is the best-in-class
data analytics system in Hadoop and in
Apache HBase but Google didn't just stop
doing our research and engineering in
these areas we've continued to advance
the technology year-on-year to help
power all of our services that we bring
to you for example Colossus which is our
next-generation file system or Dremel
which is our scaleable sequel engine to
flume a mil wheel which are our next
generation data processing pipelines and
so today we're we're using tensorflow
for scalable machine learning and while
we're using these for our our own
services we've also made them available
to you to see dot in Google cloud
platform so you can take advantage of
these same services that have been
proven inside Google for years to not
power your products and your
applications and your services that
you're bringing in to your customers and
like I said this infrastructure powers
Google's eight billion plus user
services Google search Chrome Google
Maps YouTube Gmail Google Drive but
let's pause from and we let's actually
think about what these systems are at
their core and are they are they
actually what they appear to be on their
faces Gmail just a system for sending
and receiving email is YouTube just a
video content delivery system or is
Android just a mobile operating system
what I what I do argue is that these are
actually massive massive globally scaled
analytical engines that leverage machine
learning to bring personalized results
to our users when and where they need
them Google Cloud delivers data analysis
through industry-leading analytics and
ml when
where you need them with security and
privacy in the forefront of our design
we have core for key design principles
for our data analytics stack and these
are top of mind for our customers first
our server list data analytics
infrastructure our leadership in that
space we are designing a data analytics
stack where we have designed a data
analytics stack for the public cloud
paradigm we're not lifting as shifting
traditional on-premise architectures
into the cloud this enables our
customers all of you CDOT to stead of
focusing on traditional infrastructure
like they normally would do to focus on
analytics which is really what we want
is to focus on the analysis of the data
that we're collecting we're building and
offering a comprehensive set of core
data analytics workloads from data
warehousing to streaming data analytics
to business intelligence to AI and ml
this is a lot this unlike vendors with
one-off solutions this this allows our
approach to this is a much more holistic
view of a data analytics platform we
also let our customers operationalize
machine learning end-to-end
ml training and prediction is just one
piece of the puzzle but offering up a
seamless ability to collect store
transform process and prepare data for
ML gives us an end-to-end solution
we're deliberate in making our ml stack
simpler for organizations to adopt so
they can derive information from their
ml initiatives faster and finish off we
know this this Google has proven this
the usefulness of this infrastructure
through the services that we offer we're
at the forefront of data analytics and
ml innovation for the past two decades
and the solutions and frameworks are
available to our customers today who are
now adopting this and running their
mission-critical data analytics
apps on top of Google cloud but it's not
just the cloud technology that Google
offers that's important here it's also
our history and innovation in the
transportation space organizations need
reliable real-time data within
user-friendly views for to empower
employees to respond to customers
demands and needs Google Maps offers
visualization navigation and analytics
to help leading enterprises chart new
territory and to build transformative
new opportunities nobody understands
cities and what happens with and then
and the people who live there Waze
offers up a data exchange partnership
where we provide in Salem incident and
slow down data to our government
partners governments gonna take that
data to both help them respond to
accidents more effectively and also
analyze congestion to find where they
could make improvements driving today is
not as safe or as easy as we would like
and wham-o that our mission is to make
it safe and easy for people and things
to move around the world they're
building a completely self-driving
technology that will improve mobility by
giving people the freedom to get around
it helps save thousands of lives that
are today being lost to accidents
so let's let's get into dayz and what it
is
so first the acronym data analytics
intelligence system there's a flurry of
activity at CDOT which is intended to
improve the acquisition processing
management curation and quality of the
data sets C dot has tackling those
fundamental problems we'll all see dot
to enhance the utilization of data
create applications and solve use cases
that are becoming critical in the
rapidly transforming transportation
space West Maur who fortunately couldn't
be here the head of in a policy
innovation at C dot along with the
mobility operations team is leading the
charge for cloud computing
opting cloud computing and real-time
data processing with the goal of
enabling data analytics and modeling
capabilities across cidade the Daisy
platform has the potential to solve many
use cases delivering better decision
support and moving us closer to
data-driven decisions making there are
many use cases that transportation use
cases that co-op focus is on and this is
just a quick sample for example
transportation planning winter op
operations or situational awareness
these use cases are supported by a
myriad of disconnected systems such as
sa P which has has all budgeting and
financial information Salesforce was
have which holds construction and
project details - roads roadway sensors
for real-time mobile operations
Daisy is the data services and systems
layer which aligns the use cases and the
requirements with transformed enriched
and coalesced data from sources source
systems and empowering end users to
achieve seed ops key performance
measures days will also be the hub for
new enabling new applications across the
d-o-t by delivering historical and
real-time data and also leveraging AI
and ml for predictive analytics so with
all this in mind Google capabilities
with data ingestion exploration and data
science preparation of processing and ml
training tuning and predictions this
architecture enables Daisy to become a
server service analytics engine for a
complete end-to-end lifecycle deliver
NCS mission to bring intelligence and
insights to the transportation space to
their transportation network so now I'd
like to introduce theft who's going to
come in and talk to a deeper dive into
building Daisy Daisy with data
[Applause]
thanks Chris my name is f del G I'm a
technical lead on the dayz project
working with Google cloud and cloud
reach so when we kicked off this project
several months ago the first thing we
had to do is assess all the different
data sets that were available at CDOT
across their entire kind of technology
ecosystem first thing we really
discovers that there's kind of two major
categories of data for ADOT or for
transportation that's around either
geospatial data or streaming video data
and Andrews gonna talk a lot about the
video streaming data in a second but I'm
gonna go into some of the geospatial
data and some of the kind of
capabilities were unlocking by using
that data geospatial data is really just
any type of data that has a geographic
component to it so a set of coordinates
associated with that with that data so
we then broke that data down into a few
different kind of major data domains
that are critical to DoD operation and
that's really around speed weather and
incidents so speed how fast are vehicles
traveling relative to speed limit and
kind of moving averages and then vehicle
volume on the highway system right now
that's primarily detected using some
side fire radars that are fairly old
some of that data that often comes out
of it is a buggy or an inadequate
weather data weather data right now
Reseda is is collected using these Road
weather information system devices that
also live alongside at the roadway so
this becomes kind of an IOT play as we
start getting into this the third data
domain is around incident data so
basically any kind of traffic incident
that gets logged by the d-o-t operators
into their kind of traffic management
system so those are what we're calling
sort of the legacy data sets one of the
things we wanted to do was enrich that
with some new data so that we can get
kind of additional value out of data
sets are available publicly or through
different organizations so for speed
data we brought in data from ways waze's
crowd sourced data that that we can
track when jams are starting to build up
on the high
systems and that gives us a better
picture of the roadway health according
to speed so right now see dots detecting
speed using an algorithm that really
only takes into account the data coming
from sci-fi our radars so by bringing in
Waze data we can get kind of additional
value out of that weather data this is a
really cool data set produced by the
National Center for Atmospheric Research
called pike alert pike alert has these
vehicles kind of traveling up and down
major trucking routes in Colorado
particularly i-70 and it detects road
conditions so if it suppose an icy road
or there's a the snow on the road you'll
you'll get back data around snow depth
or whether that Road and Sita need to be
treated incidents so Waze is another
great dataset for incidents crowdsource
accidents that people are putting in can
be now added in addition to the d-o-t
events that are getting logged so we
want to make the state a little bit more
accessible to do T users chris mentioned
that this data existed in a lot of silos
all over the d-o-t it was in salesforce
s ap we're gonna do this massive Oracle
data warehouse migration so we basically
brought in terabytes of historical data
into Google Cloud bigquery and we set up
this sort of abstraction layer on top to
make it a little bit more accessible to
someone who maybe who has a lot of
domain expertise in the transportation
space but doesn't want to be bogged down
with trying to remember what table to
join on to derive value out of those
data sets so we created simple kind of
business friendly entities at the top
view layer in the form of views and
bigquery and create a dataset called
8dayz mark with that we're using a
business intelligence tool looker that
utilizes these these same entities to
kind of democratize this data a little
bit more so here's kind of a simplified
view of our of our architecture really
it's all kind of centered around pub sub
pub sub enables us to basically use
streaming data across all these
different data sets so even in cases
where we're batching in data so ways we
might be reaching out every five minutes
to get the latest ways data we could
still translate it to pub sub and have a
series of pub sub topics that are kind
of like you could think of it as like
spigots you would attach your hose to to
pull in that data so it enables any
really application or user
to pull in data from ways or data from
the IOT devices and and build out their
applications with it we're pushing all
that data into bigquery and BigTable and
on the right you can kind of see like
how we're looking at Daisy and sort of
like a three-prong platform you have
event-driven data and pub/sub I can
mention before near real-time data in
Google Cloud BigTable and the analytics
layer that uses bigquery and looker
geospatial data so I mentioned before
that geospatial data is it's kind of
special it's kind of important to see
dot and we wanted to use some kind of
best-in-class tools to to sort and
analyze that data so geo Mesa is our
first one geo base is an open-source
tool for basically massive geospatial
query and ingestion it stores in Google
Cloud BigTable and it does all its
processing in Apache spark so you can
run it on a data processor it transforms
indexes and then it stores that
geographic data for rapid access so you
can query basically on either time or
Senate kind of geography you could pick
like a window of space on a map and then
get all of the data available through
there geoserver is the other tool we're
using and that's our mechanism to share
that geospatial data so it uses geo Mesa
as its back in data store we're running
it on google kubernetes engine and it
publishes data it's really any kind of
geographic data standard including geo
JSON goj Suns kind of emerged as a de
facto standard for sharing Geographic
data over the web so a couple use cases
that after a few months really we're
able to unlock using the computational
power of Google Cloud bigquery so see
how it has its concept of a road segment
the road segment is really just a
stretch of road between two points going
a single direction and that road segment
has a set of geographic coordinates
associated with it so using Google Cloud
bigquery we can basically attach these
ways accidents or incidents off to the
road segments so when you're querying or
someone who the transportation planner
is querying on the health of that road
segment not only do you get the events
at the d-o-t log
you also get
waise accidents so this is a really
powerful new tool that we can unlock
using the computational power of Google
Cloud bigquery that using their on Prem
data warehouse just just wouldn't have
been possible
enabling situational awareness and
replay so this concept of situational
awareness is a understanding what's
going on in the d-o-t so if you ever go
to a d-o-t operation center they've got
all these maps and all these different
like camera views all over the place and
they're talking between ways and Google
Maps their own mapping systems to kind
of understand what's going on
so with the architecture that we built
were enabling this mechanism to kind of
build out some kind of situational
awareness layer and on top of that we
can now using the the platform replay an
existing event so a few weeks ago there
was this big storm in Colorado they
called it a bomb cyclone and we were
able to capture that data using kind of
our Daisy platform and it gives us the
opportunity to replay that event and
watch how all these different layers
kind of inter played so that a
transportation planner can go back
review an event and understand how they
can better prepare for it in the future
capo da GL is an open source mapping
tool produced by uber which I think it's
pretty cool that there's this sort of
disruptive technology that we can now
kind of reapply to the d-o-t which is
you know been around forever so I'm
using Kepler is just a mechanism to demo
out this kind of geoserver geo Mesa data
processing system that we've we've set
up here so this is kind of a cool video
it's um
we're basically replaying all the ways
accidents that occurred during the bomb
cycle and you can see that they kind of
just dip to nothing here because so few
people are on the roads but but this is
sort of like it gives an interactive way
of a user to kind of take a look at the
the roadway health and create sort of
geospatial visualizations which is a
capability that we're not even possible
in the previous ecosystem similar thing
with speed so we can kind of detect
highway speeds it's gonna go really red
in a second and the cool thing is that
the animating kind of millions of
entities right here that were pulling in
from geoserver we're just getting at geo
JSON endpoint pushing it into kepler GL
that uber tool and then we can we can
immediately animate in the replay across
a historical set so this really is just
a demonstration of the kind of future
capabilities that were trying to unlock
by building out this underlying platform
in that infrastructure we have a lot of
really kind of powerful tools at our
disposal with that I'm gonna pass it off
to Andrew I'm gonna be at the Google of
public sector booth and I'm happy to go
through the kind of that demonstration
of Kepler a little more detail if you'd
like to see it Thanks thanks F hi
everyone my name is Andrew Schwartz and
I'm a product manager for video AI here
at Google cloud at Google cloud AI we
have the mission to empower enterprises
to transform their business with AI for
C dot video is a great example of this
transformation
CEDA currently has hundreds of roadside
cameras collecting valuable information
every day however this information has
not been fully utilized as has been too
difficult as reliably in scale bleed
analyze these videos and collect the
data from them however that is why C dot
decided to leverage the power of Google
cloud a AI to help them bring
intelligence to these legacy camera
systems without the need for replacing
them for higher resolution and higher
processing power cameras at Google Cloud
III we offer two types of AI building
blocks to help customers build or add
human-like capabilities to their
products the first I'd like to talk
about is the pre trained api's the pre
trained api's allow customers to
leverage Google predefined data sets to
meet common use cases and fully train
models based on the latest breakthroughs
in AI technology and research the second
is auto ml even for expert data
scientists it's quite difficult for them
to train and program custom computer
vision machine learning models which is
why we created Auto ml auto ml in Abel's
even non-programmers to leverage a
simple user interface
to create custom models all you have to
do is upload label datasets and then
with a simple click of a button train a
custom computer vision model fit to
their specific domain or specific use
case and deploy it to production today
building upon this really excited
announce that we've added additional
functionality to our video intelligence
streaming or video intelligence api's in
the form of streaming capabilities now
enterprises have the flexibility to not
only process large video archives that
are stored in Google Cloud storage but
also to analyze videos in real time and
get actionable insights right in the
spot with live streaming support we have
initial support for live streaming
protocols such as HLS rtmp and RTSP
initially so with the power of the pre
trained models and the streaming API
Cena is able to bring intelligence to
their existing camera feeds for instance
CDOT leverages or pre-trained object
tracking API to extract valuable
information and set different types of
vehicles and track their movements
throughout the day this information
helps them understand traffic patterns
as well as identify trends and make
decisions off of it or they can leverage
our label detection in auto amel to
monitor road conditions to identify
whether it's snowing or whether there's
snow on the road which can further
enrich weather data as part of DZ the
streaming API allows customers to
leverage or harness the power of cloud
to do video processing at scale but it
gives them the flexibility to take the
results and either process it further on
Google cloud or to view the results
on-premise in their application to help
you get started and easily connected the
Google cloud streaming API we provide AI
streamer which is our ingestion library
and a set of sample code to easily and
process the byrds chunk the videos and
send it to cloud for you here we provide
a simple architecture or sample
architecture for how you might connect
and utilize the streaming API AI
streamer takes in the video feeds and
sends it close clawed for analytics and
storage
with this you can then run the
pre-trained video intelligence api's to
extract valuable information from your
video feeds and then pipe the results in
the cloud pub/sub where that information
can then be passed to your application
in the cloud such as it is for Daisy or
back to your application on-site for a
visualization so what does this all mean
it means that when you construct a
valuable of video information you can
combine it with Daisy data other data
daisy data sources you can solve real
transportation problems you can reduce
costs you can optimize roads we can help
you get home quicker from work we can
make the road safer for you and to have
you spend more time doing what you love
and less times or less time spend on the
road connects will kind of show a quick
demo of one of our object tracking API
is running or preaching models running
on one of Daisy camera feeds
this is pre-recorded but if you would
like to see a live streaming demo you
can come by the public sector booth
later today or later this week and see
actually a live feed being adjusted as
well as the bounding box is overlaid for
the different videos so with this you
can track the movements of different
vehicles crossing through an
intersection and keep these data or
store them in part as part of Daisy next
Chris will actually tell you some
information regarding this around how
much data is actually being extracted
from these videos even with a small
number of cameras currently
thanks Andrew so to pivot a pivot on
what Andrew talked about with a video
streaming 8 or the video television
streaming API a few weeks ago we
deployed video streaming infrastructure
from Sadat's
on premise data center to Google cloud
the Daisy platform and we've been
collecting data ever since on only 4
cameras so I want to quickly just kind
of give a view of how we're using this
metadata in a in addition to the bounty
box the video stream that you saw how
we're using this metadata to gain
further insights that see not originally
did not have so see how it has roughly
488 some odd cameras connected to their
network in addition to a thousands of
others that are connected of a cellular
these cameras are all legacy devices
that are not intelligent they're not
giving data out there just lives they're
just live streaming so that an operator
can view it on the right hand side I
have a one of the cameras happens to be
in in south of Denver and on i-25 and
that's that's a still image of that
camera
we've been extracting data around
vehicle counts both total by hour by day
and averages by weekday and you can see
each those heat maps accordingly and now
we could take these non intelligent
devices extract data from them and have
insights into what is visible in that
live stream and this would correlate if
you look in the in the heat maps there
it would correlate to increases in
traffic volume throughout the day
aligning with what we would normally
know is as our commute times so give me
idea of the volume we're operating out
here so for cameras they've been
operating for 13 days and over that time
we've ingested over 60 million data
points for labels and over 21 million
objects now granted not all of this data
is necessarily useful for every use case
but just think you went from almost zero
data points besides what a human would
see out of a camera
- now ingesting all this data into a
scalable data warehouse and bigquery so
now we can analyze it both real-time as
well as historical so to give you a view
of like where where we're going where
we've been and where we're going here's
a tentative roadmap for what this
partnership is going to go forward with
so starting in March you see at the
bottom we did our executive review that
closed out phase 1 for phase 1 we
delivered a Technical Systems plan for
the Daisy system we build out core
infrastructure for Daisy as well as
multiple data integration pipelines we
also did we're doing a full sync of all
their historical data from their Oracle
data warehouse and we have a migration
plan for that as well
we also delivered a technical system
plan for a modernized Colorado traffic
management system now going forward
we're looking to continue building out
more of the core system build out
multiple data integration pipelines
beyond what we have today and if you
remember the slide back we had all those
myriad disconnected systems there's lots
of those that we need to build pipelines
and get into Daisy so we'll continue to
do that we'll do a full migration of
there to Oracle data warehouse we're
building multiple real-time
visualization interfaces such as the
example that Zef showed with Kepler
we're also going to explore build doing
the development for a modernized
Colorado traffic management system and
modernizing and hosting their code
Riptide or public facing website in GCP
being powered by real-time modern api's
from Daisy we're also going to explore
building a data discovery platform in a
real-time data hub that CDOT will use to
both do data analytics broadly across
the d-o-t as well as new application
development
so in closing C dot and Google have
partnered to build Daisy which will aid
C dot and delivering on their key
performance measures for example
improved safety and mobility increased
social equity highly responsive traffic
operations and collaborative data and
information sharing and communications
so right before I end just I'll
reiterate if you want to see live demos
of
of the technologies we've shown go to
the industry solutions area and the
public sector booth specifically and we
have multiple live demos that you can
look at and also you can ask questions
to members of the dayz team so thank you
for attending the session I hope
[Applause]
[Music]